[Musique]
on vient de faire chier à
ça
je suis avec mes deux [__] là
mademoiselle
je suis en train je suis tranquille
bon vous m'avez donné rencard aïe ça y
est j'allais fermer la lourde
alors tu sais tu sais toutes ces poutres
apparentes elles apparaissent pas
quand tu arrives n'importe qui elle
disparaît elles sont apparues parce que
Ardisson est apparu
historique c'est ici
la rédaction de joie
toute la grande tout tout
ça voilà et tu habites toujours là quoi
je peux avoir un glaçon je sais où on
était là chez Adam c'est la soirée tu
connais Adam
c'est une boîte de tous c'était la
soirée le premier jeudi du mois ces
soirées des sommiers des soumises
alors par exemple puis il y a des filles
qui font de table des filles qui font du
sport
c'est bien moi tu sais
j'aime bien les lunettes leur sexe leur
trou du cul et tout ça mais je pense que
le trou du cul il y a la mer de bout
la chatte il y a de la
carte blanche des pertes noires et tout
ça mais la bouche c'est bien
vous êtes d'accord
d'où tu descends alors tes copines elles
sont sympathiques comme tout hein
tranquillou dis-moi
il y a un truc moi qui m'a toujours
fasciné dans ta vie c'est l'Indochine
parce que il n'existait pas le Club
Méditerranée à l'époque donc pour
voyager il y avait dans l'armée il
fallait faire la guerre et j'étais
attiré par l'Extrême-Orient et tout et
puis c'était ça a été beaucoup je suis
tombé complètement amoureux
d'Extrême-Orient c'est arrivé quand tu
es arrivé tu étais où tu es à Saigon non
non
j'étais là-haut dans le Nord Tonkin
j'étais vraiment à la frontière de Chine
j'étais dans l'infanterie de marine au
départ et puis après je suis tombé dans
les parachutistes coloniaux en fait
j'étais habillé c'est bien passé
c'était habillé normalement on n'aura
pas dû me voir puisque j'ai tortue
camoufler
je suis resté deux ans et demi
tu te fais pas exprès ouais tu tires
dans le tas de la gueule c'est rentable
ça va c'est papa et tout ça fusil ou une
mitraillette ah bah à l'époque on avait
quand même déjà des mitraillettes et tu
tirais comme ça quoi
on tire sur la gale
[Musique]
extraordinaire en plus parce que
les gars qui allaient en Chine ont été
vachement mal vu en France tu sais qu'on
se faisait [__] des pierres sur la
gueule et moi je vais te raconter
une anecdote c'est que quand je suis
rentré de France je croyais que j'étais
à un héros et j'ai débarqué sur le
paquebot pasteur et finalement le
pasteur est arrivé au petit matin elle
nous a on nous a fait tenir jusqu'à la
nuit parce que on avait peur des des
émeutes des mecs de la CGT de c'est des
gros compte communiste tu as des gros
con de communiste de merde syndicat de
CGT donc qui nous jette des pierres tout
ça donc on est
la nuit la nuit
et jusqu'au soir nous intéresse c'est
dans le bateau parce que vous deviez
sortir la nuit sinon les gens vont
travailler on a traversé Marseille la
nuit dans des camions bâchés
jusqu'au camp Sainte-Marthe tu vas pour
ne pas qu'on se fasse agresser
deux ans et demi c'est ça tu étais pas
revenu en France pendant 2 ans et demi
là-bas et quand tu es revenu on t'a
caché oui
engager volontaire je vais bien porter
ça extrêmement rayon tu sais à l'époque
on était tous alignés
le communisme tu te rends compte et moi
je veux les contre tous ça avec mes 19
ans extrêmement rayon tu vois c'est
cassé la gueule dans les bars quand tu
sortais de tout seul d'ailleurs on
sortait jamais tout seul dans dans
surtout on a fait nos
nos stages commando
dans la zone rouge du Midi qui sont
devenus le pénis aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
ah c'est grand con c'est les mêmes gros
cons voilà tout le midi c'est dommage ce
sont des gros cons un jour ils sont
communistes un jour sur le pénis mais
heureusement ils ont le pastis
et dis-moi tu as eu envie de faire
l'Algérie après
non je vais t'engagé pour la Corée ah
oui moi l'Algérie pour moi c'est trop
près de la France tu vois ah j'étais un
pays que j'aime pas non non pour moi je
voulais aller loin
ah je te jure c'est vrai je te jure
après tu voulais repartir encore mais
c'est les Américains quand je me suis
engagé volontaire j'aurais pu m'engager
pour non je me suis engagé pour
l'Extrême-Orient et quand je suis rentré
dans le sud c'est ce que je fais
volontaire pour la Corée je te jure
c'était bien habillé les Américains et
tout ça et manque de peau la garde de
choré s'arrête l'armist battle
l'armistice là omunjone l'armistice donc
c'est pour ça que je suis pas là encore
une ça c'est sûr que j'avais en plus
extra brillant et puis la Corée c'était
une étoile avec un indien c'était beau
sur le blouson exonérer le blouson vous
avez jamais vu le blouson les annuaire
si tu sais tu sais en France on est
vraiment des cons ils ont jamais bien
habillé l'armée militaire c'est pour ça
que plus personne quand tu as vu arriver
les bosses en France tu as vu comme on
était habillé les moches en France les
balles tout ça
tu vois arriver les Américains
attends c'est un blouson qui arrivait
jusque là qui était cintré là d'une
beauté tu as raison parce que
comment était sapés on avait presque des
bas de Molière dégueulasse
il y avait des tailleurs chinois j'en
disais voilà vous allez me faire ça et
ça et il m'avait fait pour moi
détailleur chinois mon blouson Noël
dans la qualité que je leur avais dit en
soi alors j'avais des Rangers et vous
avez c'était des grandes gueulasses
comme j'ai un petit peu encore
maintenant on est arrivé jusque là qui
était belle comme tout tu vois lasser tu
fais des belles chaussures de cuir de
cette couleur là assez jusque là avec le
pantalon c'est qui avait un élastique oh
[__] hé
tac tac tu descendais dans les bordel de
Saigon comment c'était les bordel de
Saigon ah bah c'était beau le rêve quoi
c'est il raconta tu vois
par exemple je reviens repartir à les
revoir mais j'ai tellement peur d'être
déçu tu vois mais à l'époque c'était
c'était
tu rentres chez un coiffeur entre couper
les cheveux et en même temps il y avait
un petit boy qui te passe en dessous
on t'avait coupé les cheveux tu étais
rafraîchi tu avais sucé la [__] c'était
extraordinaire les
gutenba qu'on gagne un ami
[Musique]
dans le village de le Cnam il y avait
une furie d'opium
le village de lucnam à côté de iPhone il
y avait une petite Piome comme ça
on s'allongé sur la nappe
et on nous bourré une petite pipe de
Piome une petite boule blanche
taille basse
une petite boule blanche
c'est du rap c'est du rap indochinois
bien sûr mais c'est du rap quand même
bon alors j'ai vécu Indochine comme ça
bon et
j'avais quand même c'est mon amour de 20
ans elle s'appelait
mon amour de mes 20 ans c'était la
première fois que que je baisais que
j'encais que je me faisais sucer par une
petite indochinoise tu vois donc il y
avait quand même un amour qui s'était
installé là
et quand j'ai quitté de Chine
s'intégrale
c'était une petite niacoe
qui était dans son quai quoi
et
c'est sûr que je n'ai pas partir comme
ça à quitter
le village où j'avais rencontré alors je
lui dis écoute ma chérie on va aller à
hillphong
et je vais te payer le plus grand hôtel
d'iPhone qui se plaît
juste en face la paix d'Halong
et alors on a passé là la petite nacoué
je vais payer vraiment alors elle était
allé chez le coiffeur elle est allée
chez le coiffeur
et tout ça elle était belle ravissante
et tout ça
et puis
il faut qu'on se quitte puisque le
bateau était là
il va partir dans deux heures et tout ça
donc
s'embrasse dans le tel on se pleure dans
les bras
je reviendrai ma médaille Mamina ça veut
dire chérie on a de chinois tu vois
Mamina je reviendrai
mon minoi tu reviendras et tout ça bon
et je prends mon sac marin sur l'épaule
et je dis il faut pas que j'ouvre le
bateau et je bats je me barre vers le
port d'iPhone pour prendre au bateau
et j'entends derrière moi des petites
plaquettes en bois clac clac clac clac
clac elle me poursuivait aide ma grappe
parle par la chemise et je me dis [__]
je vais quitter mon bateau c'est ce que
j'ai fait je me suis retourné Thierry je
me suis retourné et je lui foutu un
grand coup de poing
et je laisse semer j'ai vu ces petites
plaquettes en bois
et ça y est j'ai pas rater mon bateau
à moi je l'ai laissé chaos
sur le port de iPhone
[Musique]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu